so everyone loves sanctions they seem
like a relatively painless way to punish
people who deserve to be punished
vladimir putin for example a lot of
people were very upset about the
invasion of ukraine understandably so
why not sanction putin but there are two
questions that you should have to answer
before you move forward with a policy
like that the first is do the sanctions
punish the people they're intended to
punish and the second is are there
unintended consequences that we should
be thinking about good intentions are
not enough you have to care about the
effects of your policies that's how
adults make decisions
are these adult decisions that are
helping us and hurting putin clint
ehrlich is a russian policy analyst
he joins us tonight to assess those
questions clint thanks so much for
coming on so to the first are these
sanctions hurting vladimir putin that's
the point are they working
no the sanctions are helping vladimir
putin his approval rating has actually
gone up in russia 10 points from 61
percent to 71 percent now and so even
though the sanctions may be hurting
russia they're consolidating putin's
power within the country and making him
a more robust enemy of the united states
well but wait that's kind of the last
thing we want to do isn't it and by the
way i i just want to assume for the
purpose of this conversation good
intentions on the part of people who
back sanctions i think most people who
are for sanctions think that they work
but you're saying they're having the
opposite effect
i know individuals on the ground in
russia who are frankly anti-putin and
pro-western before this happened and
they've been impacted by these sanctions
so much that they're now really turning
against the the west your viewers may
not realize this tucker but
international calls into russia are
being blocked today when russians try to
call home they get a message telling
them to go explive themselves and so
these are cruel measures that are making
the russians turn against us in a a
really uh significant way they're
they're angry they're angry at us about
the way that they're being treated
russians who don't support the invasion
of ukraine who don't support putin i
think it's an interesting point are
there counterproductive effects effects
of sanctions that might hurt the united
states i think
that's probably something we should
think about are there any that come to
mind
certainly what we've effectively done is
started to re-erect the the iron curtain
it was our policy during the cold war to
try to integrate russia uh with the west
to try to integrate them politically and
economically instead what we've done is
isolate them and so essentially we've
created a new north korea but this time
with 6 000 nuclear weapons and so that
doesn't advance our national interests
and frankly it threatens global security
so if you're kicking russia out of the
global financial system
that's an idea that has actually been
affected we've done that
um but you gotta wonder if that might
boomerang and make the united states
less influ influential over time in the
global financial system is that a
possibility it's already happening today
any any state has to consider the risk
that if it holds dollars as a reserve
currency for its central bank that those
assets or other fiat assets that are
under the control of the west could be
frozen and so russia and china have an
incentive to create essentially a
parallel uh economy separate from ours
so that they won't be under our control
it frankly undermines our influence very
directly
last question econ 101
everyone who looks at the united states
realizes that if the rest of the world
were to stop buying us debt the united
states would grind to a halt and no
longer be a rich country i mean
instantaneously
does any of our reaction to the russian
invasion of ukraine make it more likely
that other countries will stop buying
u.s debt uh certainly i mean uh there's
there's a real threat uh that they could
uh stop uh buying uh our debt uh and so
we're undermining really our our most
valuable uh asset uh that way you know
we're living on borrowed time
economically and we're getting into uh
an economic war that we may not leave
unscathed i think every american most
are horrified by this invasion should
ask their lawmakers is anything you're
doing making it less likely the rest of
the world will buy our debt will start
unloading our debt and what would be the
consequences of that dumbo
clinton relic i appreciate
thinking like an adult we don't hear it
very often you do clearly so thank you
for that
my pleasure thank you tucker